vi siete mai chiesti come mai ci sono
delle persone che da subito ci sono
antipatiche a prima vista non hanno
ancora iniziato a parlare è già ci
stanno antipatiche oppure al contrario
ci sono delle persone che ci piacciono
subito meravigliosamente oppure al
contrario delle persone di cui abbiamo
paura per delle questioni che proprio
non riusciamo a comprendere bene queste
altre domande sono delle questioni che
interrogano la psicologia della mente da
tanto tempo e che cosa iniziano a
spiegarci che esistono dei neuroni
chiamati i neuroni a specchio che si
accendono nel momento in cui
semplicemente noi osserviamo qualcuno
quindi non facciamo che non parla ma che
sta facendo un'azione che nella nostra
mente richiama il bisogno noi ci il
nostro cervello si accende esattamente
come si accende il cervello dell'altra
persona
addirittura ci sono dei momenti in cui
ci posizioniamo nella stessa maniera in
cui si posiziona la persona che stiamo
osservando che cosa succede questo
perché avviene in realtà questi sono
comportamenti innati avete presente gli
uomini primitivi quelli di tanto tanto
tempo fa beh provate ad immaginare di
essere lì dove c'erano pochissime
risorse alimentari di luoghi di
protezione le caverne erano poche erano
piccole ed erano pericolosi
il compenso c'erano tantissimi pericoli
ovunque pericoli alimentari perché le
cose che si mangiavano non sempre erano
sicure pericoli che provenivano dal
resto del mondo dagli altri esseri umani
che vivevano su quello stesso territorio
pericoli provenienti dagli animali era
necessario per l'uomo salvaguardarsi
come poteva farlo come avrebbe potuto
farlo costruendo un pensiero che potesse
proteggere solo le persone appartenenti
al proprio gruppo di riferimento alla
propria stretta cerchia familiare
inizia così a considerarsi il concetto
di yin group cioè tutte quelle persone
che fanno parte della nostra cerchia
famigliare e che noi riconosciamo simili
a noi tutti gli altri sono pericolosi
perché ci possono portare via le risorse
perché possono venire e ucciderci perché
possono arrivare e depredare il nostro
territorio è il nostro out group
ora il problema è che a furia di vivere
nell in gruppo succedono dei grossi guai
provate a immaginare che cosa significa
proliferare in ambienti in cui siamo
tutti sempre facenti parti della stessa
famiglia
purtroppo nascono degli obbrobri cioè la
mutazione genetica è pericolosa e lesiva
per l'essere umano e poi pensate al cibo
si depaupera sempre di più perché non
c'è possibilità di innesti nuovi di
nuove contaminazioni per l'essere umano
questa predisposizione innata questi
comportamenti sono in realtà che
sembrano protettivi sono in realtà
nocivi
allora l'uomo deve decidere in qualche
maniera per evolvere per essere dove
siamo oggi di cambiare strategia deve
decidere per forza che qui le
propensioni innate in realtà sono più
nocive di quelle che sembrano essere se
vogliamo davvero includere noi dobbiamo
partire da questo presupposto
naturalmente ci viene la propensione di
dire che noi ci proteggiamo dalle
persone appartenenti ad un altro gruppo
da un out group e cerchiamo di
proteggere le nostre stretta cerchia
familiare per questo è un comportamento
che facciamo tutti quanti
quotidianamente nella nostra storia
anche tutti quelli che si credono bravi
buoni belli non razzisti pronti ad
accogliere tutti gli altri lo facciamo
tutti lo facciamo tutti perché fa parte
della nostra storia
allora il primo concetto che vi chiedo
su chi presso quindi vi chiedo di
prestare attenzione e questo non
neghiamo non neghiamo le nostre
difficoltà non neghiamo i nostri
concetti non negozi non neghiamo le
nostre per concezioni siamo consapevoli
di quello che siamo
siamo consapevoli delle nostre strutture
della nostra storia del luogo da cui
arriviamo non neghiamo la differenza del
nostro outlook vi racconto un episodio
io sono una donna che mi reputo energica
faccio un sacco di cose da sola
vado in macchina soprattutto
in giro per almeno per il piemonte
faccio delle formazioni a cuneo parte la
mattina alle 5 e mezza
guido la mia macchina tranquilla e
serena fino a 220 km 230 km
faccio il mio attore di formazione e
torno indietro non ho mai chiesto mio
marito di accompagnarmi non ho mai
chiesto mia mamma di accompagnarmi lungi
da me fare questa cosa io reputo di
essere una brava guidatrice un giorno ho
pensato addirittura di sfidare mio
marito e gli ho detto sai che se io e te
facessimo una gara io vincerei
sicuramente ovviamente dopo una sonora
risata di lui mi ha detto marta prima
che una donna batta un uomo sulla guida
ce ne vuole un sacco di tempo
io rimango della mia idea lui rimane
della sua idea circa due settimane fa
era in macchina con mia figlia e andavo
a novara una persona davanti a me ha
fatto una manovra ai quanto scorretta
mettendomi in difficoltà
la prima cosa che mi è venuta in mente
quando mi sono girata verso questa
persona è stata guarda sarai sicuramente
una donna ma come io io che reputo di
essere una donna brava guidare queste
categorizzazioni appartengono a tutti
noi perché ciascuno di noi considera
quello che nella propria storia
familiare come il proprio in gruppo e
quello non lo mette in discussione io
appartengo a una generazione in cui le
mamme dei miei compagni di classe erano
donne che lavoravano molto poco spesso
lavoravano a casa sicuramente si
allontanavano poco del proprio
territorio
era normale per me immaginare o sentirmi
dire che erano il papa che guidavano con
la macchina
sono cresciuta con quell idea e oggi pur
essendo una donna che guida la macchina
continua a pensare ea dire che gli
uomini guidano meglio la macchina per
cui la prima cosa su cui dobbiamo
prestare attenzione non neghiamo non
neghiamo noi stessi
non neghiamo le nostre concezioni la
seconda idea su cui voglio porre alla
vostra attenzione allarghiamo la nostra
cerchia sociale costringiamo c ad
allargare la nostra cerchia sociale
facciamo una lunga lista delle persone
che conosciamo delle persone che
frequentiamo delle cose che siamo
abituati a vedere sempre e delle persone
con le quali siamo abituati a
confrontarci quasi quotidianamente
sempre un po di anni fa sempre in
macchina dovevo andare a fare un
intervento con dei ragazzi di scuola
superiore ad arona e avevo bisogno però
di una mediatrice culturale
ovviamente siccome sono sempre io quella
che va in macchina
posso prendere marian e andiamo insieme
verso arona in macchina io conosco maria
mi da un po di tempo la guardo le dico
maria ma ti vedo stanca c'è qualche cosa
che non va rimi dice ma no marta
tranquilla non ho solo dormito molto
bene questa notte sei sicura poiché ci
fermiamo avere un caffè non ho ho
bisogno solo di cinque minuti di tempo e
di un pò di silenzio e io mi sono messa
a guidare senza accendere la macchina
poi la vedevo davvero un po affaticata e
rieletto marian sicuro che vada tutto
bene
marta ti posso chiedere una cortesia ma
certo sempre io è sempre quella che si
reputa aperta attenta curiosa sempre io
ma certo mari anche prova c'è dimmi che
cosa hai bisogno posso mettere il velo
perché io lo so che quando arrivo dai
ragazzi lo devo togliere il velo perché
crea una barriera perché loro non
capiscono il significato ma io questa
mattina non ho pregato come si deve
non mi sento ancora a posto con la mia
coscienza e senza il velo io mi sento un
po nuda ho bisogno di quel velo ma certo
maria ma figurati ma bastava che me lo
chiedesse perché nella mia mente si
iniziava ad aprire un concetto per cui
quel velo non era soltanto sopraffazione
oppure un obbligo di legge oppure
qualche cosa che uno doveva fare perché
così era scritto ma iniziava a diventare
un bisogno personale individuale
esattamente come quello di una mia
paziente che tutte le sere deve pregare
i suoi cari che sono mancati compresa la
sua mamma
carta prestissimo nell'ordine esatto in
cui loro sono morti e se lei non riesce
a farlo in quell'ordine li sente di non
potersi addormentare serena perché non
gli ha salutati correttamente non ha
prestato loro un pezzetto di pensiero
non cambia niente cambio solo
l'espressione ma il bisogno intimo
profondo è lo stesso peccato che io
quello di marian siccome non mi
appartiene
non lo sapevo riconoscere mentre invece
quello della mia paziente mi era più
comodo più semplice vedere capire
incontrare allarghiamo la nostra cerchia
sociale costringiamo c a parlare con
persone che la pensano in maniera
differente da noi che vivono situazioni
diverse da noi che hanno esperienze
differenti da noi altrimenti vi
succederà come devo ammettere è successo
a me in questi ultimi periodi di
svegliarvi un giorno sicuri certi di una
vittoria elettorale e poi strabiliante
mente accorgersi che questa non era vera
perché il mio riferimento era sempre
solo l'ambiente che votava la stessa
cosa che volevo io
terzo punto diciamo ciò che vediamo
diciamolo con onestà diciamolo a tutti
alle persone a cui vogliamo bene
soprattutto perché vi capiterà anche a
voi di essere a tavola con i vostri
genitori con i vostri amici con i vostri
figli e sentire quelle frasi
meravigliose che usiamo tutti quanti noi
piene di quelli assoluti che fanno parte
della lingua italiana
tutti mai sempre quanti omosessuali ci
sono a milano è piena ormai ci sono solo
loro ma ma non vedi quanti sbarchi ci
sono ci sono più stranieri nel mondo che
italiani che cosa succede allora
fermiamoci abbiamo il coraggio di dire a
quelle persone
guarda che forse non è proprio sempre
così forse gli omosessuali ci sono ma
perché adesso gli possiamo osservare vi
possiamo guardare hanno un nome e un
cognome possono vanno al bar
tranquillamente non perché sono di più
mi è capitato una volta che la mia nonna
mi ha detto a
questi giovani di oggi che sono degli
sfaticati e irriverenti e io l'ho
guardato non quei giovani di oggi sono
io sono io alla coletto dicevi ma basta
marta lavorare non è possibile che tu
torni così tardi che tu fai questione
piccole sono gli stessi sono vogliamo
solo che a me concedi questa cosa qui ea
tutti gli altri decidi che non va bene
allora fermiamoci a dire alle altre
persone non con aggressività ma con
coraggio quando vediamo delle cose che
non vanno che quelli assoluti non fanno
parte di un mondo inclusivo perché
sapete qual è la verità
sapete chi c'era in macchina con me due
settimane fa su quella strada fra
trecate novara c'era mia figlia alla
quale io ho detto le donne non sanno
guidare le sto già consegnando un
modello dentro con quale lei crescerà e
se noi abbiamo rispetto delle
generazioni future dobbiamo iniziare a
pensare che le parole agli atteggiamenti
che ne utilizziamo raggiungono proprio
loro e chi vorrei consegnare a lei un
mondo più inclusivo più capace di
guardare la capacità di essere
differenti senza che in questa
differenza si veda soltanto la
sopraffazione il pericolo ma anche la
ricchezza è vero i comportamenti di
inclusi in group si basano su
propensioni innate ma non sono un
ostacolo vanno solo indirizzati
indirizzati per rendere il mondo quello
che oggi
ricordiamoci che l'incontro avviene tra
stranieri altrimenti sarebbe parentela
grazie
[Applauso]